chers collègues nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir monsieur du blé secrétaire
général de l'association anticorps et
Madame Bernard juriste au sein de
l'association madame Bernard monsieur
dublé nous vous souhaitons la bienvenue
et vous remercions de vous être rendu
disponible pour participer à cette
audition vous le savez à partir du 10
juillet 2022 plusieurs membres du
consortium international de journalistes
d'investigation ont publié ce qui est
désormais convenu d'appeler les
uber-files s'appuyant sur 124000
documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine datée de 2013 à 2017 cette
enquête a dénoncé un lobbying agressif
de la société uber pour implanter en
France comme dans de nombreux pays des
véhicules de transport et chauffeurs des
VTC venant concurrencer le secteur
traditionnel de transport public
particulier de personnes réservées
jusqu'à leur au taxi dans ce contexte
notre commission d'enquête est deux
objets d'une part pour objet
d'identifier l'ensemble des actions de
lobbying menées par uber pour un simple
planter en France le rôle des décideurs
publics de l'époque et émettre des
recommandations concernant l'encadrement
des relations entre décideur public et
représentant intérêts et d'autre part
pour ambition d'évaluer les conséquences
économiques sociales environnementales
du développement du modèle uber
l'ubérisation en France et les apporter
et à apporter par les décideurs publics
en la matière
votre audition s'inscrit davantage dans
le champ de notre premier sujet compte
tenu de l'objet de l'association
anticorps créé en 2002 pour lutter
contre la corruption rétablir l'éthique
en politique d'association a d'ailleurs
publié le 22 avril 2022 un article
intitulé pour libérer la décision
politique de l'emprise des lobbies et
formuler plusieurs recommandations donc
nous souhaitons d'abord connaître votre
perception sur les révélations des
uberfall c'est sur nos travaux les
uberface met en évidence que
l'entreprise uber a pu s'adresser
directement à des ministres à des
cabinets ministériels même si les
auditions que nous avons réalisées
jusqu'à présent montrent que la
stratégie du beurre a systématiquement
échoué les modifications législatives
adoptées en France on renforcé les
contraintes sur les VTC et les
plateformes comme uber et les enquêtes
administratives ont bien eu lieu et
conduit à des condamnations
au-delà des révélations des
uberfils notre commission d'enquête
s'interroge sur le dispositif actuel
d'encadrement des activités de lobbying
des entreprises auprès des décideurs
publics nous avons eu l'opportunité
d'auditionner un stand d'experts de
responsables de la société tel que tel
que vous-même nous souhaiterons donc que
vous puissiez nous faire part de vos
recommandations sur ce sujet en
particulier depuis la loi Sapin 2
puisque la loi sapinay comme vous le
savez elle rentre en vigueur après les
les faits que relatent les
uberfils je vous remercie pour la
qualité de vos réponses avant de vous
laisser la parole pour vous présenter
quelques minutes répondre à ses
premières interrogations et entamer les
échanges sur la forme de
questions-réponses avec mes collègues je
vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires un poste de
personnes additionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vais donc vous inviter
à lever la main droite activer votre
micro et dire je le jure
je le jure
merci je vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur messieurs et Madame
donc comme vous le savez et vous l'avez
rappelé anticorps nous sommes une
association de lutte contre la
corruption pour la provité publique et
donc nous ne sommes pas un service
d'enquête et nous n'avons pas par
définition vocation à identifier les
actions de lobbying qui ont été menées
par
uber pour pouvoir s'implanter en France
de même on ne sommes pas habilités de
par notre part notre notre objet social
à nous prononcer sur les conséquences
économiques et financières et même
environnementales du développement du
modèle
uber en France en revanche l'ambition
d'anticorps c'est de réhabiliter le
rapport de confiance qui existe entre
les citoyens et les représentants et
c'est à ce titre que nous aimons des
recommandations sur l'encadrement des
relations qui existent entre les
décideurs publics et les représentants
d'intérêt
nous ne considérons pas que le lobbying
constitue en soi un problème
démocratique il est normal que des
parlementaires des hauts fonctionnaires
des cabinets ministériels consultent le
les représentants des parties concernés
avant d'élaborer ou de voter la loi mais
pour que
cette action apparaissent légitime aux
yeux des citoyens il est extrêmement
important que les activités de ces
groupes de pression soient parfaitement
transparentes parce qu'à défaut ces
activités elles ne constituent plus la
défense d'un point de vue dans l'espace
démocratique mais elles peuvent confiner
et je l'expliquerai après parce que
c'est notre objet social au trafic
d'influence
c'est pour ça que nous anticorps on a eu
plusieurs plusieurs affaires dans
laquelle dans lesquelles on a été amené
à porter plainte notamment avec
l'association form indép en 2018 qu'on
trouve six experts de la Haute Autorité
de la santé qui étaient chargée
d'évaluer le traitement de l'hyper
collée
et qui ont entretenu des liens d'intérêt
avec des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
qui commercialisaient ces produits et à
la suite de l'initiative d'anticorps la
hase a abrogé sa recommandation le volet
judiciaire il est toujours en cours de
même en 2019 on a signalé au parquet le
cas de la députée sylvie Goulard qui
avait reçu
324.000 euros
de l'Institut
Bergen
et elle explique que c'était pour des
conférences et des réunions que les DJ
de notes mais voilà on avait on avait
quelques doutes et de même dans
l'affaire
uber files c'est bien l'opacité des
relations entre le ministre de
l'Économie et l'entreprise de beurre qui
a posé une difficulté les rencontres
entre Emmanuel Macron et les
représentants de la société uber elles
ne figurerait pas à l'agenda du ministre
de l'économie et cette opacité elle est
problématique parce qu'en fait elle
laisse imaginer le pire aux citoyens et
elle entame à ses profondément la
confiance que ces citoyens peuvent avoir
dans les institutions et dans leur
représentants
je sais pas si
on va continuer on a un petit peu
ce qui a ce qui a vraiment été appelé
anticorps c'est qu'il y a ça pour
l'Assemblée nationale pour les
assemblées parlementaires il y a eu une
énorme progrès qui ont été faits en
matière de contrôle du lobbylisme même
si c'est encore insuffisant que
constater qu'il y a énormément de
progrès qui ont été faits au niveau du
poids exécutif c'est quand même beaucoup
plus faible on est beaucoup plus en
retrait et c'est ce qui nous pose
problème chez anticorps c'est-à-dire
qu'on a pu voir le patron d'une
entreprise privée des marchés
directement à ministre c'est qui qui
était Emmanuel Macron à l'époque je
crois qu'il était mission d'économie ou
du budget qu'il a démarché directement
pour avoir une influence sur le pouvoir
exécutif hors force et de constater
qu'en France c'est comme ça le
l'essentiel du pot l'essentiel de
l'initiative législative appartient au
pouvoir exécutif vous votez
principalement des projets de loi qui
vous sont apportés par le gouvernement
or rien ne dit et là on n'a pas moyen de
savoir que dans projet de loi on n'a pas
eu de l'intervention auprès de cabinet
ministériel auprès de ministre de
représentants d'intérêt privé et c'est à
dire que vous votez vous en tant que
législateur parfois des textes dont vous
ne pouvez même pas vous n'avez pas la
vous n'avez pas forcément les sources et
ça ça nous pose problème chez anticorps
il y a il faut vraiment faire un effort
de transparence
au niveau du poids exécutif et de
l'influence des lobbies et pour ça on a
certaines propositions qui seraient une
très grande avancée démocratique selon
anticorps
et notamment ce que nous proposons
on a plusieurs plusieurs propositions en
matière de contrôle du doubisme mais la
principale qui a nos yeux serait une
formidable avancée démocratique serait
la création d'une plateforme sur
laquelle les lobbies les représentants
d'intérêt privé il y a pourraient
avancer leurs arguments il y avait
évidemment un plateforme ouverte au
public et à tous les citoyens et sur
laquelle également des citoyens une
expertise citoyenne pourrait se faire et
de là pourrait émerger
une solution qui irait d'un intérêt
général parce qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
interrogez vous devez le savoir quand
vous interrogez les les citoyens les
électeurs beaucoup d'entre vous beaucoup
d'entre disent mais de toute façon les
décisions sont prises en faveur de
certains types de population ou de
certains types d'entreprises et comme le
disait Inès ça laisse
penser ça peut laisser penser à
certaines personnes que quand une
décision est prise en faveur d'une
entreprise ou d'un représentant
d'intérêt privé il y a une contrepartie
au culte je ne dis pas que c'est le cas
mais dans l'esprit de beaucoup de
citoyens
on pense qu'il y a une contrepartie
mais donc à terme enfin contrepartie qui
veut dire corruption ou atteinte à la
probabilité publique
en effet d'ailleurs un sondage qui a été
publié en 2019 au terme nickel il
apparaît que 79% des citoyens
considèrent que les décideurs sont trop
influencés par les lobbys donc nous on
considère que cette que la décision
publique elle doit être libérée entre
guillemets de l'emprise des lobbies et
surtout je voudrais insister sur une
chose qui est importante pour nous au
regard de l'objet social de notre
association c'est que parfois ces
activités d'influence elle confine ou
elles peuvent même donner lieu à des
infractions pénales au premier rang
duquel le trafic d'influence et la
corruption par exemple si un lobbyiste
il promet où il verse des avantages
quelconque un décideur qui soit public
ou privé pour l'amener à prendre une
décision l'infraction de corruption elle
peut se trouver caractérisée et
l'avantage ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il peut prendre la forme d'une
invitation il peut prendre la forme d'un
voyage qui trait offert de sorte que la
frontière parfois extrêmement mince
entre certaines pratiques des lobbys et
les infractions à la probité il est
extrêmement important vous comprenez
d'éviter ces dérives et pour cela
l'activité des lobbies auprès des
décideurs publics elle doit être
rigoureusement écartées donc nous on a
a pas écarté oui elle doit être
rigoureusement encadré pardon et nous on
a analysé à cet égard la loi Sapin 2 qui
constitue évidemment une avancée qui est
considérable puisqu'il a elle a créé le
registre des représentants d'intérêts
qui est héberger vous le savez sur le
site de la hatvp mais il nous semble que
son décret d'applications à vider une
partie de ce dispositif de sa substance
et en fait de son effectivité ce qui
nous pose une difficulté on a analysé
quelques points qui nous semblent
vraiment embêtant et extrêmement
perfectible d'abord c'est la définition
du lobbying qui est prévue par par la
loi et qui exclut les activités
d'influence qui sont intervenus à qui
plutôt qui circoncis les activités
d'influence à celles qui sont intervenus
à l'initiative des décideurs publics or
on le sait il y a des groupes de
lobbying qui sont extrêmement installés
auprès des décideurs et il se trouve que
les décideurs les politiques peuvent
être amenés à
consulter directement et on considère
également que les responsables publics
les décideurs ils ont une responsabilité
dans le choix des personnes qui le
consultent donc on pense que cette
spécificité là et sa définition là elle
doit être modifiée de même il y a la
définition des décideurs publics elle
nous a parlé très restrictive et vous le
savez par définition le président de la
République il est pas considéré comme un
desserts publics ça ça nous ça ça nous
pose une difficulté ça nous paraît assez
peu compréhensive concernant les
décideurs locaux vous le savez également
depuis la loi du premier juillet 2022
les la définition de décideurs publics
étendu à des en sortant de décideurs
locaux mais à ce titre
la loi s'applique uniquement aux maires
des communes de plus de 100000 habitants
et ça ça nous paraît un seuil qui est
trop haut on considère qu'en fait des
mères de communes de petites communes de
plus de 50 000 habitants peuvent être
amenés à faire enfin être à faire
l'objet d'activer de d'influence qui
sont importantes donc on considère qu'il
devrait être inclus dans cette
réglementation de même il y a un certain
nombre de groupes qui sont exclus la
définition du lobbying et qui ne sont
pas soumises à l'obligation de
déclaration ce qui nous semble enfin ce
qui nous pose une difficulté c'est le
cas des associations à objets
culturelles qui peuvent être amenées
pourtant à avoir des activités
d'influence qui sont importantes dans
les sujets qui les qui les concernent
vous le savez certainement un certain
nombre de personnes morales de droit
public qui sont exclus également de
cette définition de l'activité
d'influence et à ce titre des états et
je sais pas quand on a vu ce qui c'est
ce qui s'est passé récemment au
Parlement européen avec l'influence du
Qatar et du Maroc ça nous semble être
dommage de pouvoir exclure les les États
et la plupart des personnes morales de
droit public de de des personnes qui
peuvent avoir une activité les
associations des lus sont également
exclus et un certain nombre de syndicats
sont partiellement exonérés de la
réglementation aussi surtout pour ce qui
révèle du dialogue social ça nous semble
être une difficulté une autre difficulté
c'est le risque du comptoir d'ornement
parce que les critères sont assez
complexes je pense que vous l'avez vu
les critères de définition sont très
complexes pour
que une personne morale ou privée soit
soumise à l'obligation de déclaration à
la htvp il faut soit que la
représentation d'intérêt ce soit son
activité principale soit qu'elle exerce
cette activité de manière régulière
alors pour que ce soit son activité
principale il faut que ce soit plus
qu'elle soit constitue plus de la moitié
de son temps pour que ce soit une
activité régulière il faut que sur une
période de 12 mois elle est fait plus
donc c'est précis un de 10 actions de
représentation d'intérêt ça c'est
apprécié de manière individuelle pour
les personnes morales c'est-à-dire que
dans une personne morale il faut qu'il y
ait une personne physique qui est qui
répondent à ces critères donc qui soit
est passé plus moitié de ton temps à
faire du lobbying soit et fait 10 actes
de lobby dans l'année donc en fait on
comprend à la lecture de ces conditions
que c'est assez facile de contourner la
réglementation par exemple on peut
imaginer une personne morale dans
laquelle en fait tu aurais trois quatre
personnes qui feraient du lobbying
4 5 fois dans l'année et qui serait du
coup exclu de la réglementation qui
n'aurait pas l'obligation de déclarer
leurs activités d'intérêt à la hatv donc
ça ça nous semble être une limite de de
la loi
de même
on a le PDG une entreprise de VTC qui va
faire une action d'influence auprès d'un
Ministre alors que lui-même enfin la
société française Hubert n'était pas
répertorié comme représentant un intérêt
privé et ça ça pose également problème
c'est-à-dire que toutes les rencontres
devraient être rendues publiques et les
propositions je répète un joli tout à
l'heure les propositions des des
représentants d'intérêts privés ce qu'il
souhaite porter doivent être rendus
publics et pouvoir faire l'objet d'un
élément je rappelle quand même chose
vous le savez je me permets de le dire
quand même c'est que l'essence même de
la démocratie c'est la délibération
or pour pouvoir délibérer sereinement on
doit pouvoir délibérer à partir de
critères objectifs qui vont dans le sens
de l'intérêt général et quand on a une
comme ce qui s'est passé avec uberface
une délibération qui est quasiment
imposée par un ministre on peut se poser
des questions
de savoir si les actions ces
représentants d'intérêt privé vont
réellement dans l'intérêt général et
c'est ça qui aujourd'hui pose énormément
de questions auprès de nos concitoyens
et qui délégitiment un peu aussi bien
les assemblées parlementaires que le
pouvoir exécutif et on entend on voit ce
qui se passe ces dernières années où il
y a une remise en cause de nos
fondements démocratiques je pense que le
paluderface en particulier mais cette
action du lobbying qui n'est pas
suffisamment transparente participe à
cette délivitisation de notre système
démocratique et c'est très grave
absolument et pour revenir sur un point
un peu plus technique
une limite aussi de la réglementation
actuelle qui était créée par la loi
Sapin 2 c'est que à notre sens les
activités qui sont actuellement
déclarées à la TVP la manière dont elles
sont déclarées elle ne contiennent pas
nécessairement les informations qui
permettent de faire un contrôle effectif
en fait des activités d'influence
puisque en l'état et vous le savez
certainement les représentants d'intérêt
ils ne sont pas tenus d'exposer les
positions qu'ils ont défendues auprès
des décideurs publics mais uniquement
l'objet de leur activité d'influence
dans le dans le même sens il ne sont pas
tenus enfin il n'est pas possible de
rattacher sur le sur le site de la hatvp
l'activité d'influence avec une décision
publique et on y reviendra tout à
l'heure dans nos propositions ça ce
serait une avancée importante ça
permettrait en fait même aux citoyens de
mieux contrôler et de mieux comprendre
la manière
selon la loi a été formé en quelque
sorte il y a un autre point sur lequel
on voulait enfin revenir concernant les
limites de cette loi c'est ce qui nous
semble enfin quelque chose qui nous
semblerait une
avancée importante qui serait
l'interdiction absolue des cadeaux qui
sont faits au décideurs publics les
représentants d'intérêt vous le savez
ils doivent s'abstenir de verser des
armées toutes rémunération aux
collaborateurs du Président de la
République aux membres des cabinets
ministériels aux collaborateurs d'un
député d'un sénateur ou d'un groupe
parlementaire c'est une disposition qui
est extrêmement importante c'est un
nouveau cadre juridique qu'on salue
évidemment mais on attire votre
attention sur le fait que les c'est
seulement les cadeaux d'une valeur les
cadeaux avantages quelconque d'une
valeur significative qui sont qui sont
interdits et ils nous apparaît un peu
choquants pour les citoyens que les élus
puissent recevoir dans tous les cas des
cadeaux de représentation d'intérêt
surtout que la question le critère de la
valeur significative il nous paraît
quand même un petit peu un petit peu
vague et on pense que la
représentation nationale gagnerait à
interdire totalement cette pratique qui
est déjà interdite d'ailleurs pour les
fonctionnaires ou soit l'interdire soit
faire en sorte que ces cadeaux soient
reversés par exemple à l'Assemblée
nationale on peut on peut imaginer
je me permets une intervenir quand même
il faut savoir une chose c'est que dans
les entreprises privées un salarié ne
peut pas recevoir de cadeaux de la part
d'un partenaire commercial ou d'un
partenaire financier il ne peut recevoir
strictement aucun strictement aucun
avantage c'est c'était ça va peut aller
même jusqu'au sanction pénal dans le
cadre notamment des négociations
commerciales
en revanche au niveau de
l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat du
gouvernement on peut voir des
représentants d'intérêts privés
c'est-à-dire des partenaires
les partenaires qui peuvent faire des
cadeaux même s'ils sont des cadeaux très
maudits ça pose quand même problème ce
qui est formellement interdit aux
citoyens que l'on contrôle aujourd'hui
moi j'ai une entreprise je suis obligé
de absolument justifier la moindre de
mes dépenses au niveau de l'Assemblée
nationale du Parlement du pouvoir
exécutif on est beaucoup plus large
beaucoup plus tolérant et ça ça pose
également un problème d'équité et
d'égalité ou les citoyens ont
l'impression d'être traités de de façon
de oui de façon un peu
j'ai pas le terme en tête mais
d'être très comme des citoyens de
seconde classe par rapport aux élus
alors je dis pas que c'est la vérité je
dis que c'est le ressenti on le voit
nous on a on a des groupes locaux
répartis dans toute la France et on a
des remontées de de ce que pensent les
gens et aujourd'hui on a ce sentiment
qui est là que le politique s'exonaire
de certaines obligations que lui-même
impose aux citoyens
absolument et je voulais avant de vous
parler mes propositions je voudrais
revenir sur sur deux points parmi
lesquels l'objectif de l'empreinte
normative qui est dans une de nos
propositions dont j'aimerais donc
j'aimerais un petit peu le développer ça
c'est tout simplement une recommandation
de l'OCDE dans ses recommandations pour
la transparence et l'intégrité des
activités de lobbying le CVE écrit elle
l'explique ce que c'est que l'empreinte
législative en indiquant il faudrait que
les lobbyings qui ont été consultés
leurs initiatives législatives il
faudrait assurer en temps utile l'accès
à des enfants aux informations on pourra
prendre en compte les différents points
de vue de la société
et des entreprises et disposer un site
d'informations équilibrée pour
l'élaboration et la mise en oeuvre des
décisions publiques
dans un rapport de 2015 pour René la
confiance pour renouer pardon la
confiance publique elle proposait de
faire apparaître l'empreinte normative
de la loi et du Règlement ça c'est
quelque chose qui nous apparaît
extrêmement important et sur lequel on
viendra juste après
une précision à propos de cette
problématique de l'empruntant native on
avait eu un certain nombre de députés
qui en 2017 et qui ont renouvelé ce vœu
essentiellement des des députés de la
majorité qui avait déclaré
qu'il rendrait public les actions
d'influence des lobbys et qui mettrait
en place ce système de l'empruntermative
et de l'empreinte législative de la part
des représentants d'intérêt privé on
attend toujours on a toujours absolument
rien on ne sait pas qui est derrière tel
ou tel amendement alors je dis pas que
de toute façon systématique tous les
députés se retrouvent entourés par une
horde de représentants d'intérêt privé
de lobby mais il est certain que on le
sait les lobbies interviennent auprès
des députés pour la rédaction
d'amendement et il y avait une promesse
qui avait été faite et on attend
toujours les résultats de cette promesse
sur cette question de l'empreinte
normative de la loi et du Règlement il y
a tout le débat autour de la traçabilité
des amendements je sais que dans ma
pratique de député
moi ça peut être avec fierté qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale je vais dire tel
amendement a été travaillé avec la
Fondation Abbé Pierre ou avec
telle association telle collective tel
syndicat et donc créer pour que dans le
débat on comprenne du point de vue de
quel intérêt ou de quelle expertise
se situe la proposition et à ce moment
là la transparence permet que ce soit
des battues dans les scandales des uber
files on a eu vent du coup de
d'amendement clé en main proposer par
par la plateforme à différents députés
sur différents textes de loi
sans que les députés soient tous au
courant de la provenance parce que
parfois ça passait par des ministres
rendant l'opacité encore plus importante
y compris dans la période postuber files
ou bien parfois
c'était le cas dans l'audition que nous
avons pu avoir du parlementaire Luc
Bello Hubert proposait des amendements
clients en main du vélo assume la
provenance et il estime est en accord
idéologique il porte l'amendement sans
expliciter sa provenance de manière
publique ce qui là par contre biaise le
débat les conditions du débat
démocratique et de la définition
d'intérêt général mais surtout il n'a
pas connaissance qu'à ce moment-là le
deuil le deal passé entre
Emmanuel Macron alors ministre de
l'Économie et l'équipe de dirigeants du
bien France c'était que le ministre de
l'Économie apporterait la vie
défavorable à ses amendements transmis
clés en main et qu'il y avait un
objectif de l'heure
dans le débat parlementaire pour ensuite
faire passer le deal qui visait à
supprimer uberpop pour pouvoir faire
rendre légitime l'abaissement des
exigences de formation qui permettaient
à Hubert de d'inonder le marché avec
beaucoup plus de VTC ayant affaibli les
conditions donc je pense que cette
question
de l'empreinte normative elle est
extrêmement importante
pour
garantir plus de transparence mais en
même temps il est très difficile de voir
quel est le cadeau de contraint c'est
pour ça que je trouve que votre
proposition de
de plateforme sur lesquelles
l'ensemble des lobbies peuvent mettre
leurs amendements mais il faudrait aussi
pouvoir que les citoyens puissent
pouvoir mettre pas simplement leur
propre amendements eux pour montrer une
la contradiction mais il faudrait que
d'autres puissent dire je sais que tel
lobby développe telle argument parce que
si on est que enfin vous voyez qu'on
comprenait la difficulté c'est à dire
que les lobbys cherchent parfois ne pas
rendre public vous avez parfois des
lobbies qui vont déposer un amendement
et l'envoyer enfin qui vont envoyer un
amendement à l'ensemble des députés
alors après les députés n'ont pas
toujours l'intelligence de se rendre
compte que tous l'ont reçu et qu'il
faudrait peut-être aussi creuser et
analyser mais
pour autant le citoyen n'en a pas
connaissance et le lobby peut très bien
ne pas mettre sur la plateforme donc on
a un peu toutes ces difficultés là
je vous laisse pouvoir réagir là-dessus
sur ces questions de plateforme je vois
qu'il est déjà 9h49 on devra arrêter
impérativement à 10h sachant qu'on a la
possibilité
par écrit d'avoir des compléments de de
propositions de votre part parce que sur
la question sur la question de la de
l'action des lobbies les
uberphales ils ont en disent beaucoup il
y a eu aussi un achat de de
d'économistes pour faire des des
enquêtes Pipo clé en main pour
peser sur l'opinion publique et sur les
décideurs publics des faux articles des
des paiements de manifestants pour qu'il
comprit le lobby puisse par la rue
manipuler l'opinion publique on a eu
aussi tous ces éléments là d'un système
de du maire extrêmement agressif dans
son action de Bing et ce qu'on appelle
pu aborder encore c'est aussi la
stratégie du Berre qui a été en France
comme partout dans le monde pas
simplement de définir quelles sont les
décideurs publics et donc de payer
beaucoup de cabines qui permettent de
faciliter les mises en relation avec les
décideurs publics mais qui a été aussi
d'avoir une stratégie de recrutement
de Disney donc uber a pu recruter David
plouf proche de Monsieur d'Obama aux
États-Unis
recruté Edouard Coop Grégoire COP qui
était un ancien collaborateur
collaborateurs du cabinet de Danin
vidalys ou encore un hélicrose
ex-commissaire européenne à la
concurrence donc il y a cette stratégies
là je ne sais pas si votre voilà
scienticore a aussi travaillé sur ces
éléments là ou en France on a par
ailleurs
la question du de la résistance entre le
pantouflage et de tous ces éléments qui
sont mis mais qui à mon avis doit faire
l'objet de de moyens de surveillance
permanente
alors justement c'est aussi un des
autres aspects du lobbying quand il
corps envisage
c'est ce pantouflage on l'a vu très
récemment je sais pas si vous m'entendez
oui
on l'a vu récemment c'était l'année
dernière je crois où il y a un an et
demi avec Monsieur Djebari qui était
transport qui a souhaité partir dans une
entreprise
j'ai plus le nombre d'entreprises mais
qui fabriquaient l'hydrogène
avec lequel il avait eu affaire en temps
que ministre du Transport pour
développer la filière hydrogène cette
entreprise visiblement se réconforter
comme un représentant d'intérêt privé et
ce propos ensuite de l'embaucher comme
directeur général c'est aussi un des
autres aspects problématiques du
lobbying et l'image que cela donne
encore une fois c'est que l'on a certes
c'est une image je ne dis pas que c'est
la réalité que nos hommes politiques se
servent au passage se servent de leurs
fonctions pour assurer leur carrière
professionnelle et c'est un des autres
aspect gravissime du lobbyisme oui
effectivement qui est le fait de
recruter des responsables publics des
responsables politiques
bien pour profiter des réseaux et pour
accroître encore ses actions d'influence
ensuite concernant la ce que vous avez
dit sur la proposition de plateformes
que nous avons effectivement tous les
lobbys ne se n'auraient pas forcément
cette bonne pratique qui serait de
déposer en Open d'État en ouvert les les
arguments mais comme cette plateforme
serait également ouverte à l'expertise
citoyenne puisque les citoyens sont
aussi des experts et on pense que ça
permettrait de faire naître un certain
débat et puis pour les lobbys qui ne
déposent pas en Open Data leur
propositions il est toujours la sanction
pénale qui est possible derrière
et qui peut être une sanction pénale
très très lourde pour justement inciter
ces lobbies à rendre absolument public
toutes leurs actions auprès des
décideurs publics
merci
c'est commentaire concernant les
allers-retours publics privés oui il
convient d'être extrêmement attentif et
à ce titre vous l'ignorez pas la TVP
elle a un rôle qui est très important je
pense qu'il faut il faut vraiment
renforcer ce rôle concernant
la l'empreinte normative en fait
l'empreinte normatif pour qu'elle soit
effective elle doit passer par plusieurs
choses nous dans nos propositions on
propose d'obliger les parlementaires à
mentionner l'origine d'un amendement qui
décide de relayer aussi à on propose de
joindre à un projet de texte la liste de
l'ensemble des personnes qui auraient
été entendues par les responsables
publics dans le cadre de son
délibération dans le cadre de sa
rédaction jusqu'à son entrée en vigueur
on propose aussi de révéler dès leur
transmission toutes les propositions
législatives qui ont été faites au
décideur public je pense qu'avec
peut-être ce faisceau au moins
l'ensemble de ces éléments ça permet
très quand même d'avoir un contrôle au
moins de permettre aux citoyens d'avoir
un regard sur sur la manière la manière
dont
les propositions législatives sont
faites on a d'autres propositions je
sais pas si vous voulez que je vous en
parle maintenant très rapidement oui il
nous reste quelques minutes en plus de
cette empreinte normatique qui serait
donc je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
vous le rappelle inclure dans la
définition du lobbying les pratiques
d'influence qui sont intervenus à
l'initiative des décideurs publics ça
nous semble très important d'élagir
d'élargir cette définition dans le même
sens et tendre l'obligation déclarer
leurs activités au sein du registre de
la aux autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique à tous les acteurs qui
exercent effectivement une activité
d'influence
ainsi parmi eux au décideurs publics
enfin l'ensemble des décideurs publics y
compris aux présidents ceux qui font
plutôt les activités d'influence qui ont
été effectuées auprès des arts publics
et de l'ensemble des décideurs publics
et donc du président de la République ça
nous semble très important ensuite
mettre en place des dispositifs de
traçabilité pour savoir comme je le dis
tout à l'heure exactement qui a
rencontré qui à quel sujet et à ce titre
d'un point de vue un peu un peu plus
pragmatique ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est de rendre transparent
les agendas des élus les agendas des
membres du gouvernement des membres du
cabinet médical et ça en Open Data en
fait l'Open Data nous donne à cet égard
des clés qui pourraient être importantes
de saisir
j'en ai également un petit peu parlé
tout à l'heure nous considérons qui
pourraient être important d'interdire
aux représentants d'intérêt de faire
bénéficier des décideurs publics de
cadeaux ou d'avantage ou alors de
d'obliger les décideurs publics à les
restituer
il pourrait être intéressant aussi de
publier les rapports et les informations
communiquées par les représentants
d'intérêt au pouvoir public et enfin on
finir là-dessus mais on en a déjà bien
parlé la mise en place d'un espace
d'expression et de confrontation des
avis divergents qui ou dans la dans
lequel tous les citoyens pourraient
s'exprimer et après avoir rempli bien
sûr une déclaration d'intérêts qui
serait mise en ligne et public également
et naturellement je vous encourage à
nous faire parvenir à la fois ces
propositions par écrit et puis aussi le
reste de vos propositions je profite de
vous votre présence pour vous interroger
sur un pas particulier parce
qu'effectivement comme vous je suis très
attaché à la transparence et le rapport
de confiance entre les élus et les
citoyens j'avais constaté durant ma
campagne que vous aviez mentionné mon
activité professionnelle sur votre site
en disant il travaille comme directeur
Europe pour être anticonsil qui se
présente comme un finetank mais surtout
enregistré auprès de l'UE comme une
instance de lobbying sans pour autant
être enregistré auprès de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique et quand on va sur le registre
de transparence de l'Union européenne
la catégorie de de registration
d'enregistrement et bien sing tank et ne
lui souhaite une citation et non pas
lobby ce qui est sans surprise puisque
cette au regard du droit américain à
five on s'y Suisse qui veut dire que à
la fois l'institution comme salariés ont
l'interdiction pénale de pratiquer des
activités de lobbying puisque c'est une
organisation à but non lucratif qui
bénéficie d'exemption fiscales et donc
j'aurais pu être inquiété par la justice
si je m'étais prêté à des activités de
lobbying donc je voulais vous demander
puisque à l'époque mon équipe avait fait
part de cette erreur et je n'avais
jamais été contacté les
erreurs arrivent mais en quoi est-ce que
cela contribue vous pensez entre le au
rapport de confiance entre les élus et
les citoyens
Serge je suis désolé j'ai pas compris
votre question c'est à dire
est-ce que vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
five one Siffredi au regard du droit
américain
enfin si c'était une activité de Simpson
qui est d'exercer dans l'Union
européenne ça ne dépend pas du droit
américain ça dépend du droit de l'Union
européenne éventuellement le droit
français de droit belge vous avez raison
mais ce que je constate ici c'est encore
une fois qui a marqué
enregistré auprès de l'UE comme une
instance de lobbying et là je vois
enregistrer en tant que sur le sur le
revenu c'était un tweet je ne sais pas
là je me souviens pas voilà non mais si
puisqu'on parle justement de de la
transparence de la vie publique et du
rapport de confiance entre les citoyens
ce qui me paraît effectivement être un
sujet important bref je vous remercie
beaucoup et comme je vous l'ai dit
n'hésitez pas à nous faire parvenir vos
vos recommandations